hey everybody and welcome back to in
tendo treehouse live at e3
I'm Sam for the treehouse joined by my
colleagues Rob and Matt and we're going
to take you back into Super Mario
Odyssey so in our first segment during
e3 if you had a chance to catch that we
took a look at the Stan Kingdom and
Metro Kingdom but in this segment Rob
you're gonna take us back in and check
out some old bits and pieces that we did
know she asked you off last time yeah
something I wanted to show off was that
each of the kingdoms why you returned to
the same handful of kingdoms a few times
they look very different depending on
the circumstances so the first time you
go to the sand Kingdom it's the daytime
and this is what we're showing you here
this is part of the floor ROM here this
is a segment from a little bit later but
you can get there if you're on the floor
and then after a little bit here I'm
going to show a bit from the nighttime
version of the sand Kingdom and then
later on we'll do some more of that kind
of shenanigan with the city Kingdom
start in the Metro Kingdom I think
that's one of these it really impressed
me over the course of development White
House Oh No Mario sorry but watching
this game come together and it certainly
still on developments there's a lot of
stuff the dev teams still working on but
within the kingdoms as they built them
out and continued to refine them and add
more content there are so many
interesting places that you can find
within each space and certainly even
over the course of e3 we're not even
showing you everything that's in either
one of the kingdoms that were showing
here when I rotate Kingdom there there's
so many interesting places to find but
it really off the beaten path I think I
should also mention that not every
Kingdom has a day in a night cycle but
they all do change depending on on game
circumstances you know right now the
desert is frozen you know Mario can
eventually solve this problem it won't
be frozen anymore that kind of that kind
of difference when I was playing this I
can't be patient when I'm on these
platforms I'm doing backflips right
around and I get killed so I know I'm
just because I can't sit stand still I
got a DD or something normal I'm kind of
the same way but I got humbled just now
by falling so I'm playing a little bit
more safe oh not safe enough you're
almost there
okay there we go so one thing I want to
mention for folks who are watching our
last segments we were using the Droid
clown festro straps but in this segment
we're going to be using
controller that is fully supported as
well as any other controller option that
we've got available for the switch so
we're mixing it up a little bit here
just to show you that smooth the
controls feel with the pro as well yeah
so this is the moai habitat home allowed
to clean up up the moai's yes guys
awesome they're kind of shy also this
here is a moon fragment or yeah
and you need five of those as you can
probably help it a little counter on the
top middle of the screen to get get a
power moon but they're scattered around
here and the other thing that's
significant about Mobile's besides their
being extremely shy and having fantastic
fashion sense yeah is that they are
capturable and which means mustache
shovel so oh that looks glorious yeah I
noticed my control prompt there is put
on take off shades why would I want to
put my shades you say it doesn't get too
bright here moais can see in visible
stuff so that little moon fragment there
that's hovering over the the poison lake
of awful is a totally gettable but also
having your sunglasses on makes them
always walk slowly so that's the reason
you don't just keep them on all the time
they're just got chilling out when they
got the sunglasses on they just kind of
take it easy but it's also really cute
when they're doing that really slow
stroll they have this really cute little
hum that they do where there's kind of
like mosey along yeah I don't know if
you can catch a hot stream maybe let's
see if we can pop the sunglasses down
there it is
so it's also going to point out that
there's these birds here that are
hovering are you know apparently
hovering in midair but of course the
moai can see that they're on this thing
and there's some collectible coins over
there but the moai can't jump so we want
to get them there's the birds are giving
you a hint of what's going on there but
you have to be brave and Trust your
analog stick skills to rock in a
relatively safe Street ah yes well you
did the hard way what what's the easy
way turn the camera right just go
straight forward I suppose if you want
to take all the sport out of it and
actually just coming back to those birds
one thing that's worth keeping in mind
in this game birds didn't know what's up
if you're not sure what to find maybe
that next moon that you need keep an eye
out for birds and see what they're
getting up to yeah you can see the
shadow of a bird up there and experience
tells me oh look it's glowy he doesn't
know little unusual for bird yeah pay
attention to birds there's several kinds
in this game and they are all meaningful
except maybe pigeons I'm not sure they
do anything I think they just make the
world a better place by just in there
and bouncing around they might just be
decorative but they're pretty cool yeah
so looking around looking around for
more bits of Moon fragments oh yeah
we've got Bowser's footprints there as
well yeah Cappy is you know if you could
haven't seen earlier segments then
that's Cappy who is your actual hat in
his native form of a white top hat these
birds seem to be reminding me oh there's
an one fragment up here and then let's
head over to this conspicuous elevator
spot here it's not worth it
sorry oh no you go ahead I was just
gonna remember oh I can't jump so they
need these elevator things and look
birds hovering yep
so just as a recap for folks or maybe
coming to us a little bit later on over
the ìiî process here and not sure what
Odyssey is all about this is Mario game
it's really in the spirit of Super Mario
64 and Super Mario Sunshine so we're
coming back to this kind of sandbox
style of Mario engineering where we've
got these really fascinating spaces that
are really densely packed with content
that you want to surprise yourself by
tracking down new things experimenting
and if you're interested actually in the
background of that kind of sandbox Mario
style content we actually just put up a
post of the Nintendo treehouse tumblr
built Rendon talking about this concept
how come you wa in Japanese this kind of
walled garden concept that came about
with bonsai and it's a really
interesting way to understand how the
developers are really thinking about the
sandbox space at their building so I
just got the last of the moon fragments
which caused a power moon to appear and
now I'm going to abandon this guy up
here where he will never ever escape he
doesn't have a family down there man and
I'm just gonna be heartless about it
it's called a foot on his shades he's
he's chill we won't forget you and your
sacrifice I will oh you gotta remember
these captured targets the same rules
still apply even if Mario didn't capture
them they still move in the same way
where the shades makes them move slow
and yeah yeah yeah come off to run away
it looks surprised with this little yeah
shades up there I'm searching for a
giant creature made of stone that they
are as bashful as they are they are sure
they could just walk across you I didn't
deal with youth they had a problem with
you so that was where that was the
daytime segment is going to show you now
I'm going to switch over to the
nighttime segment
this again is a another point and we
can't really talk about the where we are
in the story at a different spot yeah
yeah right um what I really like about
the desert here is I'm not sure if this
was the intention or not but there's a
lot of throwbacks to Super Mario Land
for me I saw the boy and that's in the
original desert type levels of that game
and we're gonna see something else in
this upcoming segment too that I think
might remind people with a certain boss
tonight yeah so here we are in toasted
Rina at night it is of course cold as it
still because it's still frozen
like I said Mario can can fix that later
but whoa
the undead honk-honk these lands so
these are the Desert Inn shows and they
make the desert sand situation much more
challenging because they keep springing
out particularly when you're in wide
open spaces and they will just keep
gathering you have to be very careful to
keep an eye on your surroundings because
even have a whole bunch of those guys so
you get behind you if you're in the
middle of something else you could
realize it there and they just there
will there's an infinite supply of them
there is no way to like deal with them
so you can like explore in safety so I
also wanted to highlight a few of the
fast travel options so because the the
worlds are huge you have be able to get
around quickly one thing if you've
activated checkpoint flag is Cappy
helpfully explains you can go straight
to it this map I have you know haven't
done much in this particular map but I
also wanted to point out the sort of
travel brochure thing we're doing here
it's there's little articles about you
know highlights of the of the areas it
done exactly like it was a you know the
sort of travel map you might get at the
hotel lobby and if you peruse that text
there might be some hints in there as
there are yes worth reading the brochure
yep it is so this is a jacksy and I
think this is what Matt was a Ludington
yeah this is it yeah I loved his voice
yes
so Jack seas are a very fast way to
travel and not entirely relaxing
exhilarating yeah let's go to the door
so they are very fast and they can just
plow through the chin shows which is
nice okay and you know as the hotel's
you can break they're immune to the
poison
you can't break but you can't break for
very long so you basically just use it
to make quick Corrections I'm gonna get
swing the camera around to show when he
breaks cuz is just his animation when he
breaks this really cute
why give me go slow and Mario just
barely holding on
yeah his facial expression when he's
ready but Jack see is pretty priceless
and these little spots that we'll see
here with the bench and the little
signpost those are actually Jack C
stands so if you need to call back your
jack see that's a convenient way to do
it yeah if I go into this building to
come out the jaxa won't be there anymore
but I could summon him again with at the
jacksie stand and it's also really fun
to just like whip around this kingdom on
the jacksie yeah she's a lot of fun but
be careful about edges yeah
and cliffs there's also one Jack C
specific sub level that I am probably
not going to attempt today because I'm
terrible at it but you didn't well it'd
have to have really good like Jack C
steering controls yeah I think if you
thought that whole penguin slide in 64
was hard Oh wait'll you try the jacks
you may as it is not for the faint of
heart
all right so here's bullet Bill's got to
capture those as we mentioned earlier
bullet bills are one of the capture
targets you can't hold on very long
because they do tend to explode and they
have this nice little headlight up front
which is really nice when you're trying
to do this precision steering in a space
like this so you can kind of line up
your positioning and then maybe you want
to give yourself a speed boost you can
do that and feel confident about where
you're heading
all right so now there's another cannon
over here basically every time you see a
platform in this particular area you
want to trade out your your Bullet Bill
because you need a fresh one and I
decided to be a daredevil and grab this
and completely my enemies destroyed each
other but you really do want to grab all
these coins yeah another little bit of
recap so we've got two different kinds
of currency in this game we've got the
gold coins traditional Mario coins which
you can collecting any of the kingdoms
and you can spend those in any of the
kingdoms as well at the crazy cap shop
but then those purple coins are the
regional currency and you can only
collect those and spend those in the
kingdom that they're from yeah that is a
lot of dye dang it confused about left
and right there for a sec I was about
say like motocross on yesterday talked
about the reasoning behind that and me
going to foreign countries myself and
dealing with this different currencies
depending on where I'm at I thought
really made sense and I thought it was a
really cool touch yeah I remember I was
in Japan for the first time and and I
was completely like I don't know what to
do with any of this money okay is this
the correct yeah I just gave bills every
time and I collected this huge a mass of
coins that I didn't know what to do with
anymore cuz know what they were worth ya
know when you always felt kind of guilty
go to a new place and you're just
holding out your money like this some of
this is the price which ones do you need
huh and here money is upside down
triangles yeah yeah which is cool yeah
and there's a lot of cool stuff you can
buy with the currencies so different
outfits for Mario is certainly harder
than there are souvenirs that you can
use to decorate the outside of your
Odyssey and also you can decorate the
inside and some other goodies in those
stores as well so it's worth hitting
every crazy Kathy fine just to see what
they've got in stock yeah
it also the cream but just as you said
that mat that the money here is upside
down hi maybe this isn't fated to be
that's right
the money here is upside down triangles
is probably a reference to the inverted
pyramid we're under the big rule I'm
gonna try this one more time and then
we'll just move on to the city material
I had planned I believe in you you got
this yeah thank you and you should your
men believe in your medicine it was now
placed I believe in next time maybe
we'll skip those coins ago for the wider
one alright there's a slightly wider
door there let's try that then and then
I'll give up
all right one other thing that I know
what of course I mentioned earlier on
maybe three as well I don't know if I
came up in the stream but just through a
conversation earlier is the fact that in
this game in particular a lot of it was
inspired by his own trip to Mexico and
how much he loved it there and the
architecture and the aesthetic there and
I think the development team has
actually drawn a lot over personal
travel that a lot of them have done in
two different places
oh well that's awesome that was not on
the stream because I didn't hear that
that's neat
it's a bit of a love letter to their
experiences traveling nothing it's a
little bit it's a lot like driving a car
without brakes well yeah and it's a lot
like oh you got it you're good
humor games there we got the arcade era
or a bit era where you had like overhead
yeah yeah oh I love how this game has
the 3d adventure has like the 2d
platforming with Mario and it also has
like these little just nods to different
genres and you're it's all in the same
game it's so great it's fun as you see
the surprises that come up as you're
going through these phases to where you
never really know what to expect even
when you go through a warp pipe right
yeah could really be anything and it
could be something very strange a very
unusual that you hit there but I know it
makes you want to explore you could just
like race to and finish the game and
save peach but you know she totally okay
to wait a little minute while you just
done this potential trap she's good
got enjoy your trip right oh and Polly
in there of course I'm mayor Polly mayor
Pauline yes so here we are back in the
the Metro Kingdom and it's daytime which
is where the the floor demo gets yeah
and the we're gonna do some regional
coins here because there is a level that
you can only get to if you've got a
certain outfit so I'm going to grab all
my regional coins that I can find and
there's actually a really interesting
will audio cue over there little further
older if we can go back in here go back
over this way a little bit further back
the way you came but that's actually a
little audio cue that tells you a loon
is nearby hmm little sparkly I don't
know if we want to go hunt it out now
but it's worth keeping an ear odd if you
happen to be here at e3 and you're
playing the demo yeah if you start very
missile noise oh I'm sorry
there yeah it pays to play this game
with headphones alright so here I am
turning myself into electricity to
travel by wires as everyone does in the
city and I say here's a couple of
regional coins and I believe that's
actually a portrait of mayor Pauline on
the on the coins right which is cool
yeah she's a very beloved civic spirit
when you talk to folks here a lot of
folks new dogs have you had lovely
things to say about mayor Pauline and
yeah she seems like she's doing a great
job running the city yeah right there's
one lady who wants to talk about how
much she loves her hat because it's just
like mayor Pauline's hat oh she's
inspiring fashion and setting but I like
that there's so many little knots of
Donkey Kong in this face that you gotta
think okay Polly like they're on good
terms now yeah oh and I was missioning
fast travel options here another one of
course is the motor scooter this is cute
which is certainly the most stylish way
for her to get around town and actually
a really nice execution of HD Rumble as
well unfortunately we can't really
communicate that clearly to folks who
are watching but it actually feels like
you're riding a scooter you feel that
Rumble in your hands as if you were
holding onto the handlebars yeah it's
pretty lovely Mario not the best driver
he's know also does not approve with
pylons his his practices all interesting
bullet rails
yeah there's rats here in this otherwise
fantasy city which is very strange to me
oh I know where there's some original
coins let's go over here
and become one of these guys for no
really good reason except that it's
super fun Oh actually webinar by should
we maybe pop by to show folks why you're
collecting these quotes oh the crazy cap
because we have a purpose well I'll show
you when we get me out okay yeah they'll
figure it out they're smart Halloween
yeah so Pauline as we mentioned at this
point and our first time we talked about
how the the actual story objected here
for help her collect up a bunch of
musicians and I guess I have choices
there's there's lots of collectible
coins all over the place and I've over
prepared and I know where they all are
now actually not remotely all of them
nice alright so I needed 15 I've got 15
get one more for good measure one more
for good measure that way I can tip the
guy alright
oh there was another one who moved there
right um sort of power tackle I can't
remember what it's called right now and
you can go into a role after that right
why yes you can
yeah this is my favorite new move I love
it yeah the world is fantastic you'll
quickly become your favorite way of
getting from A to B all right so crazy
cap stores a lot all of them are divided
into two there's a place where you spend
your yellow coins my place you find your
purple coins and this is actually the
original location so oh this is I think
the flagship store exclusive ah yes
so yeah this builder helmet might look
familiar to people who have enjoyed
other Mario games yes sir that outfit is
off the chain chomp Wow oh my god you
heard it here for a poem you hear your
first folks oh my goodness
let's got to catch on all right so now I
am fashionably dressed oh wow
nice that's really nice yeah oh and yeah
so there should in our own seconds there
are some spots that you have to meet a
certain dress code expectation yeah to
get through yeah and climbing and
rolling and this guy hi this guy he's a
simple little man I do like the fact he
has no concern at all that you were like
running and rolling around and over to
him as you would expect a bit like
inspector to do as they're on their way
to work so this is what building
inspectors and new dunks that he do they
check out the electrical wires for
fuzzies I guess sizes oh and these guys
can't wear what they're called right now
but they're bad
oh okay so this treasure chest is filled
with coins a fair number of coins lot of
coins
there's a lot of coins they just keep
coming
yeah coins of course are also how you
come back from losing a life so you
definitely want to have as many coins as
possible your disposal and there's also
some really cool stuff that's available
in the the yellow crazy cap stores
especially in the late game they start
adding more more products later on and
some of those are super fun alright so I
have to be careful now I'm down to my
last heart zoom up here and then over
here and then back down here and zoom
what assuming it is cool to be
electricity alright
and then over here all right we've got
moon fragments and god of course wash
that timing super carefully almost what
oh that wasn't that was stupid one more
time there's one more down there alright
you go shoot left it's the moment of
truth
yeah here we go oh dude good job nice
alright that made the heart go are the
moon go think about hearts coming down
to one well in a good news column that
moon will recharge you once you grab it
yeah that isn't it back good news and
yeah okay I think we got one more spot
yeah one more spot I was gonna switch to
the nighttime version of a new Dark City
which is considerably more perilous yes
you actually when you first arrived in
New York City at at nighttime and it is
it is a grim and gritty environment
it's a sea here and this is well content
that's not available in the show floor
here at e3 we've got the sand kingdom
that you can dip in the daytime so this
nighttime content is exclusive for folks
for watching our stream so thank you for
watching by the way yeah
and I love the city at night because
it's so different than the city during
the day yeah yes it's very moody and
maybe people are thinking oh maybe it's
the club scene or maybe just the bed
people are out but no gonna you'll get a
good idea grosser yeah no worries we'll
be able to help in here a second take a
look alright so and again of course this
is only a small slice of what each of
these kingdoms has to offer
yeah they're all for to exploit them for
themselves huge and convoluted and
filled with secrets ah
alright here we go we can good squit
bring the feet up again so way up there
at the top of the building so this is a
THL specific ROM that is already
activated checkpoint flag and I'm going
to hop inside here for a minute because
I want to show you both these super
gross urban sting bees you may remember
sting bees from I believe was Mario 64
they were sort of cute conical bees
these are much much and grosser yeah
there's a metaphor in Bridgeville yeah
but also I wanted this thing so the life
uh part is the only sort of traditional
powerup in the game but with so many
things you can capture it's the only one
you need there's so many different ways
you get powers in this game the fact
that Bowser was just advertising his
wedding by posting all over Allah's
goodness
it's an interesting choice yeah and he
paid someone to put a lot of them up but
not well enough to put them up right
there all pilling off yeah it feels very
Bowser so I love the the rain and like
some of it collects on the screen as you
can probably see which is super cool
they've done a fantastic job with the
water effects yeah and yeah new dog city
is kind of eerie and it's grainy
darkness you have a sirens in the
background there's obviously a lot of
bad stuff going on in the scene right
now
first responders have their hands full
because there's a giant robot
caterpillar I'm building
I think you can deal with that though
you can just take care of this little
problem well yeah so yes this is mecha
wiggler okay this is my absolute
favorite iteration at this enemy yeah
good he's he's one of the scarier things
it's better in a Mario game but I will
tell you he is the second scariest boss
to me in this game we're not gonna show
you the other one yet oh well talk about
that after Sheamus I want to know who
you're yeah you're number one bat he is
yeah click when he labs he gets those
little jitters up his legs so I need to
grab a sure after these tank guys are
called and quickly blow up the other
ones so I don't go with him and then I
need to not get shot and
turn out all the lights on the mecca we
deliver okay good good good nice
[Applause]
yay alright so now he gets mad as
wigglers or want to do I wants a big
challenges I think with the Sherm's
they're incredibly powerful but also
slow to move I mean maybe ranks so
they're not going to turn on a dime
they're not gonna be incredibly fast so
you have to be very mindful of your
season yeah if you've got a show whoa
Louis thanks dodging is a tank is is a
skill you can't really straight the tank
yeah I also like how the wiggler changed
colors when he got really angry and
started moving fast just like you would
express like your expect someone
engineer that exact behavior for some
insane reason oh okay and you can
actually shoot these big ol energy ball
things out of B if you can't dodge them
and you know shoot things oh wow nice
shooting Thanks
that is the upper limit of where my
turret can fire okay how did kind of Lee
makes you miss the traditional cuddly
wiggler doesn't it it really does
my son has a plush one of those and you
know it's it's super fun
oh wow there will never be a plush of
this thing Oh John the regular honest
one more oh no I missed it
Oh and I'm down to two hopefully one of
those has a heart in it soon yeah some
of them have hearts I'm used to having a
little more gyroscopic gaming from the
separated joy cons and I'm missing it
Oh
[Applause]
yes oh there it is nice it's so hard to
you when you're fighting this boss and
you have to trundle your way slowly how
to power up like please don't kill me
don't kill me yeah thank you whoo oh and
we got our Grand Moon so that was our
Mecca wiggler and thank you so much for
swingin by and showing us a bit more
game content yeah folks are watching
please stay tuned we're going to have
another segment coming up in a few short
minutes it's going to be me topia so
Gary to check out some very strange
adventuring we'll see you in a few
minutes bye bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]